who was somebody who helped you the most
in growing as a broadcaster over the
years obviously transitioning from
playing in the NFL for 10 years coming
to TV was there like a big homie of
yours that like really kind of helped
show you the ropes yeah day one no lie I
left the football field and I didn't
know how big Mike and Mike was I knew
how big ESPN was but when you're playing
I swear people think you're lying
I didn't watch any of them shows I
didn't know they even had daily shows I
didn't know they had NFL live I think I
believe you back then I feel like
nowadays it's hard it's very hard to
avoid it okay but yeah but back then I
get it yeah no I never heard of Mikey
Mike right I never heard of NFL live
um it was just so Random right I knew
about NFL prime time and I knew like why
Sports Center and Burman right Chris
Berman and yeah Jackson right right I
mean um uh what's my man I can't think
God Lee I'm bad I can't think of this
guy who played for the Broncos yes
what's up Lee y'all gonna kill me in the
comments Do It um but yeah those guys
and I was like that was
I made it if I made a highlight on there
right right so I'm looking around I'm
like all right I'm at ESPN day one and
they're like all right can you get up at
like five in the morning be in the
studio 5 15 and once you're on Mike and
Mike I was like all right radio show and
I was like damn like I can't take this
later so I'm like not even slighting
them in my head I'm like right I gotta
do a fight but this is my opportunity so
I'm gonna do this show called Mike and
Mike and I get there and it's Mike
Greenberg Mike Golic I just fill in for
a segment you know do a little guess
appearance I'm out and I was like I got
up at five o'clock just for one segment
and then when I was done I was like I
could see this is bigger than I thought
but how big
got off air
check my phone and it was lit up like I
signed a new deal well I was like God
dang I was like Mikey Mike they're in
every city everywhere for however many
years it was like the longest Morning
Show I mean I just remember my whole
life Mike and Mike was on it feels like
so which so which mic helped you out the
most Golick Golic now after that first
segment yeah
he literally comes to me and he's like
dude you're a Storyteller he's like
don't ever let somebody tell you any
different he's like everyone can do this
x's and no stuff there's computers for
that Etc he's like your stories please
just stick to your stories don't script
out your takes don't be rigid don't get
on that railroad track just tell stories
your experiences are insane to the point
where the next week they call me to come
in it was to fill in for Mike Greenberg
who was going and I literally did a four
hour show on Mike and Mike that's my
second week from being just from being
like one segment early in the morning
crazy and I just ran with it I never got
boxed in to the purest version of
broadcasting which is X's and O's third
and goal what should they do oh they
should play action I was like dog I'm
talking about the girls talking about
the club I'm talking about the player
talking about his life come on his
emotions I'm I'm doing the eyes and U's
not the X's and O's and I just kept
going with that because I got that
confidence from Golic when I first got
there